Okay, it's time for a fire.
My favorite story, segue, hey, this is kind
of weird.
Trump's White House advisor, Kellyanne Conway,
who just recently you might know or have heard,
she recently ignored a request to appear before
lawmakers to answer serious questions about
her hatch act violations.
Kellyanne Conway asked a reporter who happens
to be Jewish ethnically, what his ethnicity
is.
When he asked a question of Kellyanne Conway
about Donald Trump's recent comments that
some congress women who are ethnic minorities
should return to their quote original countries.
The reporter is Andrew Feinberg, who again,
but by his name, my belief is that he is ethnically
Oscan, Ozzy Jewish.
Uh, he was at, he asked if the president was
not telling those four congress women to return
to their supposed countries of origin to which
countries was he referring?
It's a good question.
And Kellyanne Conway, uh, apparently didn't
like it.
We'll pick it up there.
All right.
Speaking of, I just fall away following up.
Can we following up on the previous question,
if the president was not telling, uh, these,
these for congresswoman to return to their
suppose in countries of origin to which countries
was he referring, what's your ethnicity?
Uh, why is that relevant to this number?
I'm asking the question.
My F my, my Ireland, Hillary, my, my own ethnicity
is not relevant to the question I'm asking
you that I am asking you.
You said originally, no, no, I'm, I am.
I am asking you to, which is, which.
So are you, are you saying that the president
was telling, uh, the Palestinian American
to go back to you?
I just love the pause when she asks, what's
your ethnicity?
The reporter Andrew Feinberg in stunned into
silence.
Literally now, immediately lots of people
online started saying, is this antisemitic?
Because Kellyanne Conway presumably knowing
that Andrew Feinberg's ethnicity, not race,
notably his ethnicity is Ashkenazi Jewish.
To the extent that we differentiate between
race and ethnicity.
And it's all sort of a question at this point.
Um, I actually don't think she's that clever
to be totally honest.
I don't think that this was antisemitic.
I think it was mind numbingly stupid.
Now I'm certainly open to the idea that she
did this to an ethnically Jewish reporter.
I just have not seen any evidence of that
so far.
She wasn't, uh, you know, checking to see
why he's not wearing his yellow star that
he's supposed to be wearing or something like
that.
I think she's just a moron.
And this is potentially even a plan distraction
because if I were trying to prove how not
racist I was and how not racist my boss was,
I don't know that I'd start asking reporters
to list their ethnicities when they ask questions.
Now I hate to do this, but I feel almost like
I have to.
When I saw Kelly say, what's your ethnicity?
My mind went to when cultural critic Dave
Ruben did stand up comedy and asked audience
members their sexual orientation.
Remember when this went down?
Hot Gay comics live for television.
Uh, by a show of hands, how many of you have
televisions?
You have a pretty good.
Okay.
And how many of you have the here network?
Oh, okay.
We've got some work to do, but we're very
good.
So do we have all gay people?
Is Everyone here gay?
You're gay.
Very good.
Do we have some lots of discussion?
Like did some of you just come out right then?
Yeah, just always ask anyone you're talking
to ethnicity and sexual orientation please.
Just so that you know, and you know how to
contextualize the conversation.
So anyway, this is shaping up to be a very,
very xenophobic and racist election cycle.
And I hope everybody's buckled in for it.
Uh, is this, I mean, maybe I'm wrong.
Should this be, uh, a strategy I adopt when
I do interviews on the show where I ask for
ethnicity out.
Joining me today is Richard Wolf economist,
my former professor at the University of Massachusetts,
uh, Professor Wolf.
Before we get started, what is your ethnicity,
just so we understand?
Oh, Ashkenazi Jewish.
Got It.
All right, well, let's continue now with the
interview.
Now, Kellyanne Conway later tweeted about
this saying, quote, this was meant with no
disrespect.
We are all from somewhere else.
Quote.
Originally I asked the question to answer
the question and volunteered my own ethnicity,
Italian and Irish.
Like many, I am proud of my ethnicity, love
the United States of America, and grateful
to God to be an American.
This is such a dumb explanation, right?
That we are all quote originally from somewhere
else only confirms how outrageously stupid
Donald Trump's comment was because Donald
Trump's family is from somewhere, not in the
United States much more recently then Alexandria
Casia Cortez is a, you're not really doing
yourself any favors Kellyanne with this explanation
that, listen, we're all from somewhere.
So I was just asking you that question to
make that point.
Well that makes Trump look even worse as a
result.
We are in an age of idiocracy.
I, I, I don't know how to interpret this.
Is this as some have suggested antisemitism
by Kellyanne Conway because the reporter was
Jewish?
I don't think so, but I'm open to having my
mind changed.
Is this a deliberate attempt to distract from
the things that Donald Trump said with an
even dumber comment?
I don't know.
I sort of have a hard time believing that.
Is this Kellyanne Conway just trying to make
a point but failing and uh, embarrassing herself?
Maybe that's the most likely circumstance.
I don't know the answer, but I do want to
hear from you.
What do you think this is all about?
Uh, I do have a post about this up on Instagram.
Make sure you follow me there at David.
Dot.
Pacman and while you're there, follow the
David Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman
show for a bunch of great behind the scenes
pictures and videos and lots of [inaudible]
really great stuff.
We'll take a quick break, many more stories
to discuss with you today.
Hope you'll stay with